METE ATAMEL: Video
intelligence API
can be used to do label
detection, explicit content
detection, and shot change
detection in videos.
Let's see how to use the Video
Intelligence API with C#.
First, make sure the API
is enabled in your project
and a service account
exists to make API calls.
Both are explained in the
codelab in the video notes.
In Cloud Shell, let's create a
simple .NET console app and add
Video Intelligence API NuGet
package to the project.
We'll do label
detection in a video
stored on Google Cloud Storage.
Open the online code editor
and navigate to Program.cs.
Reference to the Video
Intelligence API library.
Create Video
Intelligence client.
Create a request pointing to
the video file in Cloud storage.
Code annotate the video
with the request and wait
for the results.
Finally, add some
code to print results.
Let's run the app.
There you go.
You just extracted labels
from a video using the Video
Intelligence API.